We saw in the previous example how sentences in a story can be ambiguous. For
example, by, could have referred to an agent, a conveyance, or a location.
This is true, not just for prepositions, but is also true of other [UNKNOWN]
categories, like words. In fact, words often can have several interpretations.
Let us consider the word take as an example. Take is a very common word.
It has at least these 12 different meanings. Consider for instance to medicate.
Ashok took an aspirin. Here, the meaning is that Ashok took
aspirin as a medication. Each of these meanings has a common meaning of take,
as we will say in just a minute. But given a sentence in which take occurs,
how do we know which of these meanings is intended by the word,
take? So suppose the input sentence was, my doctor took my blood pressure.
The taken in this sentence refers to, to measure and not to any of the others.
Let us examine this issue further. So, for each of these 12 interpretations of
take, we have a frame-like representation. So take 1 to take 12.
Each of this frame-like representation specifies the thematic roles that go with
that particular meaning of take. So in this particular meaning of take, take 1,
we have an agent and an object. In this meaning of take, take 12.
We have an agent, an article, and a particle. Another word that typically occurs
with take which signifies this meaning, so to take clothes off from a body.
Let us consider another example of particle. Let us consider take11.
The meaning of this take is to assume control, as in to assume control of
a company, or to assume control of a country. When the meaning is
intended to be to assume control, then take typically occurs with the word over.
Take over a company. Take over a country. So, over then is a particle that
signifies this eleventh meaning of take. To go deeper into story understanding,
consider the simple story I took the candy from the baby. What is the meaning of
the word take here? You and I get this immediately, but how can an agent get it?
To keep it simple, we have shown here just nine meanings of take, you could have
added the other three as well. Although we started with bottom-up processing,
we're now going to shift to top-down processing. Because there's something about
the background knowledge about candy that we have, which is going to eliminate
lots of choice. In particular, we know that candy is not a medicine, so
this particular choice goes away. We know that candy is not a quantity, so
this choice goes away. Several of these choices disappear,
because of our background knowledge of candy. Just like some of the constraints
came from our background knowledge of the semantic category of candy,
other constraints come from our background knowledge of the preposition,
from. In the table showing prepositions earlier, from referred to a source.
These three frames do not have anything to do with the source, and
therefore we eliminate them. We're left only with this particular frame,
which has source in it as required by the preposition from. And thus we decide
that the interpretation of took in this particular sentence is to steal from
a baby. And thus we infer the correct interpretation of take, in this particular
sentence. It refers to, to steal. This is the only frame that is still active